The future of data visualization looks very bright.
And I hope that you've learned a lot in this class.
Ryan, if there's something that a student taking this class walks away from
learning in this course, what would you hope that would be?
>> The one thing that I want everyone to walk away with is that anyone can do
data visualization.
You don't necessarily need to be the best coder or the best designer.
But with a few simple tools and concepts,
you too can create a data visualization that is both beautiful and compelling.
>> I want to thank you for taking this course, and
I hope you had as much fun going through the material as we had producing it.
And while we covered a lot of ground, both on the theory and practice of
data visualization, we learned how to code using D3 to create visualizations for
the web, there's still much more to learn.
I encourage all of you to join us at Ziptheme Academy or
use the wealth of online resources to continue learning and
creating visualizations of your own to share with the world.